فقد افاد مراسل الجزيره بان مسيره
اسرائيليه استهدفت سياره في مدينه النبطيه
جنوب لبنان صضح هذا المضم معنا الان من
بلده رميش في جنوب لبنان مدير مكتب
الجزيره مازن ابراهيم مازن هل رشحت اي
معلومه تتعلق بهذا الاستهداف خاصه وان
هناك صور اوليه تتعلق باستهداف هذه
المسيره للسياره في
[تصفيق]
النبطيه نعم في الواقع ازدار كل المعطيات
التي ساريد الان هي المعطيات الاوليه التي
تمكنت من القائها وترتبط بما حصل في مدينه
النبطيه هنالك سياره تم استهدافها حصل
انفجار الترجيح الاولي من قبل الاجهزه
الامنيه ان مسيره اسرائيليه اطلقت صاروخا
باتجاه هذه السياره اعقب هذا الامر تحليق
مكثف لطائرات استطلاع اسرائيليه في
المنطقه التي جرى الاستهداف استهداف هذه
السياره فيها وفق معطيات اوليه ايضا هنالك
حتى الان نتحدث عن اصابتين لا نعلم مدى
خطوره هذه الاصابات وهل استشهد احد خلال
من جراء هذا الصاروخ الذي استهدف السياره
ولكن كل المعطيات تشير الان الى وجود
اصابات هذا من ناحيه والتقرير الاولي
للاجهزه الامنيه يتحدث عن استهداف من
مسيره اسرائيليه لهذا الامر اعتبارات
عديده مهمه كبيره للغايه نحن نتحدث عن
مدينه النبطيه هي ثالث اكبر مدينه في
الجنوب اللبناني باسره هي تاتي في الترتيب
بعد صور وصيده تاتي مدينه النبطيه
وبالتالي عندما يصل الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
اذا ما تاكد بان غاره من خلال مسيره
استهدفت سياره فهذا اولا يعتبر خرق كبير
لكل القواعد التي كانت سائده سابقا هذا من
ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه ان يتم استهداف في
وسط مدينه النبطيه وتحديدا عند تمثال
الصباح في وسط المدينه فهذا يعني باننا
ازاء استهداف واضح يمكن ان نضعه في خانه
الاغتيال بمعنى ان استهداف مجموعه في
سياره في وسط مدينه النبطيه وهي بعيده
كليا عن ساحات المواجهه التي تدور هنا عند
هذه النقطه التي اتواجد فيها على طول الخط
الحدودي بمعنى اننا نتحدث عن مدينه في عمق
عمق الجنوب اللبناني فان يتم استهداف احد
الاشخاص في في داخل هذه السياره وذلك ضمن
هذه المسيره واطلاق الصواريخ هذا يعني
عمليا اننا ازاء
عمليه اختيال الم
ال السياره او الاشخاص المستهدفين على وجه
الخصوص حتى هذه اللحظه لا يمكن الح حسم
بالنسبه من كان يستقل السياره ولكن من
الواضح بان هذه السياره التي استهدفت لها
علاقه بشكل او باخر بحزب الله بطبيعه
الحال كل ما ياتي ويرد الان هي معطيات
اوليه ولكن ازدهار المكان الزمان كيفيه
الاستهداف كل هذا يشي باننا ازاءه عمليه
تشبه العمليات التي نفذتها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في عده بلدات جنوبيه خلال
المرحله الماضيه ونتج عنها اغتيال دعيني
هنا اذكرك بما حصل في خربه سلم عندما تم
استهداف سياره ايضا اتضح احد ان احد القاض
الميداني لحزب الله جرى اغتياله قبل
اسابيع ايضا في محيط مدينه صور تم استهداف
سياره اتضح بان من كان فيها كان احد عناصر
الارتباط الاساسيين ما بين ما بين حزب
الله والمقاومه الفلسطينيه وحماس حينها
جرى الاستهداف استهداف تلك السياره بصاروخ
من سياره ادى ايضا الى استشهاد احد
الكوادر الرئيسيين الذين يعنون بالتنسيق
ما بين حزب الله وحماس على مستوى كتائب
القسام وما يحصل في غزه وبالتالي اليوم
هذا السيناريو حتى هذه اللحظه وفق ما
وردني وفق هذه الصور التي نشاهدها نحن
ازاءه وفق معطيات اوليه عمليه خاصه نفذتها
المسيرات الاسرائيليه وان تستهدف في عمق
مدينه النبطيه هذه السياره ويؤدي هذا
الامر الى وقوع اصابات فان لهذا
الامر ارتباطا واضحا بكل العمليات التي
نفذتها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والتي
ادرجت ضمن اطار عمليات الاغتيال التي نفذت
تجاه القاده الميدانيين المرتبطين بالعمل
المقاوم عند الخط الحدودي هذا الامر تكرر
اكثر من مره سواء من خلال استهداف سيارات
او حتى من خلال
استهداف قاده ميدانيين في حزب الله عندما
جرى استهداف احد المنازل في بيت ياحون
وغيرها وبالتالي المعطيات كلها تتقاطع عند
هذا الامر بطبيعه الحال حتى الان لم يصدر
بيان واضح من القوى الامنيه يؤكد باننا
اذاء استهداف من خلال صاروخ اطلق من مسيره
او من خلال عبوه موجوده في المكان ولكن كل
الترجيحات الاوليه ازدهار تشير الى اننا
اذا استهداف من مسيره اطلقت صاروخ باتجاه
هذه السياره